welcome to hannity tonight joe biden he
needs to pick up the phone i suggest
call mar-a-lago
and yeah bring unity to the country as
he says he so desperately wants and
thank president donald trump because a
few moments ago
he tried to take credit for everything
that donald trump did
on covert 19 three vaccines
thanks to donald trump's operation warp
speed
there were already a million vaccines
being administered into people's arms
every single day
when biden was sworn in 36 million doses
had already been
distributed according to joe it was the
biden administration
that stepped in heroically saved america
from covert
19 none of this is true where's the
unity joe
i'm using every power i have as
president of the united states
to put us on a war footing to get the
job done
sounds like hyperbole but i mean it a
war footing
and thank god we're making some real
progress now now because all the work
we've done
we'll have enough vaccine supply for all
adults in america by the end of may
that's months ahead of schedule that
would be mcderner that would be pfizer
that would be johnson johnson and that
would be
your predecessor president trump
operation warp speed
all due respect to the president he
didn't have anything to do with that
vaccine and had nothing to do
with the mars rover either there you
have it
joe biden unity president that he is
taking credit for someone else's work
joe you want unity why don't you just
thank donald trump
you want to want us to all to get along
you say no trump
no vaccine joe stop taking credit for
something
frankly you had nothing to do with
nothing
but i do need to give joe biden a
congratulations tonight
yes he stayed up an hour past his betty
time
after days and days of practice he was
able to read from the teleprompter for
almost 20 whole minutes
without making a total fool out of
himself now the problem with this
is people are going to say see hannity
you did it you did it
it's like oh johnny hit the hit the
baseball good job
is that the lowest bar possible for a
president
isn't it a little kind of sad that we
even have to
wonder or even discuss it it's kind of
sad to me
let's be clear biden's ability to remain
lucid tonight for 20 long minutes
shouldn't be cause for celebration this
is a guy who is clearly not doing well
and the last three weeks alone
have been extremely alarming that is the
sad truth
now since the early days of the campaign
we have been watching joe and his daily
struggles that is
when his campaign rarely would allow him
to leave the basement bunker
yes rare but now joe is clearly getting
worse and again what we have seen
just these past three weeks not tonight
he practiced and practiced and practiced
and lo and behold he got through the
speech without fumbling the ball
but this is the last three weeks leading
into tonight and the hours and hours of
practice before tonight
take a look i want to thank
the the former general i keep calling
him general
my my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
the vast majority of economists left
right and center
from wall street to the to the
private private uh
economic polling initiatives
now am i supposed to speak or is swathi
going to say something
representatives cheryl
shirley jackson lee al green sylvia
garcia
lizzie pinelli excuse me
pinell and uh what am i doing here that
um
over 500 [ __ ] i have a card i carry a
card with me every day
with the total number of folks who have
been affected
okay so you see why joe has gone 50 days
with no official press conference that's
that's a higher bar it's going to take a
lot more practice
byte administration knows the biggest
liability of joe biden is joe biden
himself
you can script a prime time address and
you can practice practice practice and
barely pull it off
you can script a state of the union and
let me be honest
that's the easiest speech for any
president to give
you walk into applause shake a few hands
you read two lines you get more applause
you rest
you read two more lines you get more
applause more rest time
but it's a little harder to script a
press conference that's going to take a
lot more practice
and of course help from a compliant news
media
and although and by the way when joe
actually decides to hold an official
presser
so far it's longer than any president
last hundred years
i think the administration will probably
of course try to orchestrate the entire
event
just like they did the few times he did
it on the campaign trail
pre-selecting a handful of pro-biden
reporters in the meantime
the white house definitely does not want
joe answering any impromptu
questions we saw it happen again today
by the way
last three days only one event on joe's
schedule every day just one
after joe signed the massive 2 trillion
dollar schumer pelosi
payoff into law only 9 percent is
emergency covert relief take a look
thank you all appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you he did good tonight he didn't
have joe biden or
kamala harris near next to him that's a
rare thing
just to put this into perspective when
president trump was in office members of
the media mob
they had a mental breakdown if trump
didn't respond to jim acosta
at fake news cnn and his personality and
his insults hurled across the white
house law
now joe biden signs one of the biggest
boondoggle spending bills
that has zero basically from emergency
covert relief not a lot
nine percent takes no questions after
refusing to give
one single press conference during his
entire time in office
the media mob barely yawns there is a
guy in the oval office allegedly
running the country who appears to be
struggling cognitively and the mob
cannot be bothered to do their jobs
they're actively
willfully putting their heads in the
sand that would be
nbc abc cbs msdnc
fake news cnn um do any of you guys have
any news divisions at all do you have
journalists working for you
or not now to be honest with you and
your viewers
if you're just the mouthpiece for the
dnc in other words if you want to be a
talk show host i'm a member of the press
but i am a talk show host i have
opinions i tell everybody up front i'm
registered conservative and yeah i like
donald trump as president
uh because during the trump
administration the coverage
was a little more aggressive don't you
think
according to nearly all of their
coverage donald trump couldn't do a
single thing right
in fact they predicted that the
president's plan to develop and
distribute
colvin 19 vaccines yes known as
operation warp speed
would be another failure he not only got
it done
and got a million in people's arms a day
36 million total
but he did it while being impeached and
tried twice pretty amazing you might
remember
i think this is just further evidence
that the trump administration had no
plan for distribution operation warp
speed
was really just a plan to address market
failures
in manufacturing and development and
manufacturing of vaccines
we'll have a vaccine by the end of this
year is that possible in your view
oh brian you know it's another day of
potus in wonderland here uh
it is preposterous to make that
statement
experts are warning that kind of
timeline may be overly ambitious
and some have even argued it's perhaps
dangerous a chronovirus vaccine trump
says it could come out this year this
sort of you know
happy talk that he's doing about a
vaccine experts say
he'd need a miracle to be right here's
the thing you cannot talk yourself into
a vaccine
the fastest a vaccine has ever been
produced from start to finish is five
years you're right donald trump did it
in one and you never give him credit for
anything nothing he does is right uh
that wasn't happy talk was it operation
warp speed
thankfully for the sake of the country
in the world was a huge success
thank god for our great medical
researchers and scientists and doctors
and first responders
they did an amazing job we all owe them
a debt of gratitude
but there will be no retractions no
apologies
they will never correct the record
instead they will continue to act as
cheerleaders
for the radical democratic socialist
party who's ever running the show at the
white house